backers of russian opposition leader
alexi navalny are calling for
more protests tomorrow to protest his
jailing in russia
moscow police detained thousands of
protesters yesterday
video shows several violent arrests and
massive crowds
protesting the rule of president
vladimir putin navalny as you know was
locked up when he returned to russia
after recovering from an assassination
attempt
charlie daggett is following this story
from london and joins us to discuss
charlie can you tell her the protests
making a difference
well gail they are making a difference
because they're getting under president
putin's skin as we understand it now
this morning we've learned that
navalny spokeswoman may be placed under
house arrest one of several high-profile
arrests in recent days
but it did nothing to discourage
protesters from turning out
despite threats of jail time by the tens
of thousands they defied government
orders to stay off the streets for a
second weekend in a row
violent clashes breaking out running
street battles pitched against russian
riot police
determined to crack down on protesters
by
brute force if necessary
monitoring groups say more than 5 000
demonstrators have been detained
even more than in last week's protests
including
navalny's wife yulia ordered to pay a
fine of about
265 dollars for taking part in
demonstrations
the u.s secretary of state anthony
blinken condemned
the persistent use of harsh tactics
against peaceful protesters and
journalists
the russian foreign ministry dismissed
that as crude interference in russia's
internal affairs
accusing washington of trying to
destabilize russia
there have been demonstrations in the
past but these are different
says samuel greene director of the
russia institute at king's college
a difference in tone and emotion right
um i think that the previous
waves of of protests were often about
how putin was running the country right
um whereas this protest is very much
about getting put it out
a defiant navalny appeared at a court
hearing last week accusing the kremlin
of blatant lawlessness meant to scare
him and his followers
he blames president putin directly for
the novichok poisoning that nearly cost
his life
which putin's spokesman has repeatedly
denied
now tomorrow navalny faces another
hearing which could see his suspended
sentence turned into real jail time and
the possibility of
two and a half years behind bars tony
charlie dagger for us in london charlie
thank you very much